Around 600 BC lived
Thales of Miletus,
widely regarded as the
first Greek philosopher,
as he was the first to give
a purely natural explanation
of the phenomena he observed.
A key observation
that he made was
that certain stones-- such as
amber-- when rubbed against fur
would exhibit a
strange property.
The amber seemed to emit
an invisible force which
would attract small fibers.
He assumed this rendered
the amber magnetic,
another force he observed when
playing with lodestones, which
are naturally occurring magnets.
Many after him observed that
the contact or friction with fur
seemed to create an imbalance.
Something was
pulled from the fur
and transferred
onto other objects.
Now, not only did this result in
a small attractive or repulsive
force, but also in the
potential for shocks to occur.
Once the discharge occurred,
the force disappeared.
So the shock was some
form of discharge
which reversed the imbalance
created by the friction.
Throughout history, we
were also fascinated
with lightning bolts, nature's
most passionate displays
of power and aggression.
Most cultures assumed
this was a divine force,
outside the reach
of human hands,
and was therefore
reserved for the gods.
Up until the 17th century,
our descriptions of it
varied from an invisible,
intangible, inponderable agent,
or even threads of syrup
which elongate and contract.
And it was Benjamin Franklin
who, in 1750, set out
to prove that there was a
connection between lightning
and these tiny shocks
due to friction.
In the famously dangerous
experiment done alone
with his son, he led a
kite into a thunderstorm.
And near the bottom,
where the thread was wet,
he tied an iron key.
And after some time, he brought
his knuckle up to be key,
and experienced a
series small shocks,
identical to the ones
created by contact with fur.
This showed that,
indeed, lightning
was simply the same thing
as these household shocks,
but on a massive scale.
And at this time, people had
begun to divide materials
into two categories.
One were objects which
would allow, or accept,
discharge-- such
as gold or copper--
which we call
electrical conductors.
And interestingly,
these materials
are also generally good
at conducting heat.
And number two were
objects which would not
allow this discharge--
such as rubber,
or electrical insulators.
These materials also seemed to
insulate the transfer of heat.
And we also began trying to
measure this force that Thales
had encountered.
One way to do this
was to suspend
a piece of spongy plant, called
a pith ball, from a thread.
And when we rubbed an
insulator against fur
and brought it
near the pith ball,
it would pull on it,
causing a deflection.
If we added more
objects, we noticed
this deflection increased, due
to a greater pulling force.
We also notice that the shape
of insulators made a difference.
Large, thin insulators seemed to
exhibit a much stronger force.
And amazingly, it was found
that conductors, such as copper
wire, would transmit this
pulling effect over a distance.
This was demonstrated
by running a long wire
between the pith ball and
the charged insulator.
When the object was
brought near the wire,
it pulled through the wire
and deflected the pith ball
instantly.
When we later touch the
wire with our finger,
a discharge occurs
and the pulling stops,
and the ball is released.
Immediately, people
began speculating
that this could be the
future of optical telegraphs.
And in 1774, French inventor
Georges-Louis Le Sage
was one of the first on record
to actually set up this idea.
He sent messages through
an array of 26 wires,
each wire representing a
letter of the alphabet.
When a discharge
occurred at one end,
the pith ball would
move at the other.
The trouble with his
telegraph was that it only
extended between the
two rooms of his house.
The power of the deflection
was small and difficult to work
with.
Though at the time, people
were investigating techniques
for generating larger
charge differences in order
to amplify the force involved.
One improvement popularized
by Alessandro Volta
one year later was an
easy way of generating
discharges on demand.
It was based on the idea that
a charged insulator could
introduce, or transfer, a charge
onto a nearby conducting plate.
One needed to merely
bring the metal plate
close to the insulator, which
would pull on the charge
distribution in the
metal plate, resulting
in an imbalance, or electrical
tension, in the metal plate.
Then one could bring
their finger to the plate,
and a discharge would occur.
Then the plate is pulled away
using an insulating handle,
and an excess charge would
remain trapped in the plate.
The plate could then
be discharged at will
simply by touching it to a
conductor, such as a finger.
And amazingly, this process
can be repeated many times
without recharging
the insulating plate.
We could then generate many
small discharges at will.
And by now, Benjamin
Franklin was
focused on finding
out how to trap
or store up these discharges.
At this time, he still
assumed that electricity
was some sort of
invisible fluid,
since he knew it could
travel through water.
So he assumed that water
inside an insulator
could hold electricity.
What we now call the
Leyden jar was a glass
jar with water
inside and a metal
probe running out the top.
Franklin also wrapped the
outside in a conductive metal.
When he brought a
charged conductor
towards the top
probe, a discharge
would occur, and stay
trapped in the jar.
More importantly
was that the jar
could be charged multiple times.
Each spark would amplify
the charge separation,
or electrical tension,
inside the jar.
A good analogy is to think
of the jar as a balloon,
and each discharge as
a short jolt of water.
After hundreds of iterations,
the tension becomes massive.
And to release the
charge, he simply
touched the outside
conductor to the top probe.
A large discharge occurred.
Franklin improved
the design over time,
eventually realizing
that the charge was not
stored in the water,
but the glass.
The water was merely
a conductive path
from the probe to the jar.
Today, we would
call the Leyden jar
a capacitor, or a
charge-storing device.
And when he chained
many jars together,
he founded he could increase
the capacity even more,
and release deadly
bolts of electricity.
And over the years, people
focused on more effective ways
of building up charge using
friction machines which
could be stored in
capacitors and released
as spectacular displays
of man-made lightning.
And over the next
50 years, people
tried to design systems
for sending sparks
across greater distances using
longer wires and more powerful
discharges.
However, sending
electrostatic discharges
as a communication
method seemed clumsy,
archaic, and was no
improvement over the existing
optical telegraphs of the day.
They were widely ignored
by government and industry.
Though tides were rising--
an electric revolution
was just around the corner.